bout de feu traverse le ciel de car qui
sont les cris de joie et les
applaudissements des soldats du
craignent
c'est un avion russe qui vient d'être
abattu par un missile sol-air les
combats ont fait rage toute la nuit dans
la deuxième ville du pays
au petit matin les habitants film leur
ville défigurée
voilà ce qu'il reste de ses immeubles et
de cette école nationale d'architecturé
les murs de ce bâtiment sont criblés
d'impacts de balles
ailleurs pin à seulement 20 km de kiev
les civils femmes enfants et personnes
âgées fui délibérément vers l'ouest
helvetia quid si tu des gens sans raison
tout cela est tellement dur pour la
population c'est de la folie
pour ces familles l'évacuation se fait
au milieu des flammes la peur au ventre
parfois sous les pompes
entre deux détonations les blessés sont
évacués en catastrophe
les chars russes poursuivent leur lente
progression vers la capitale
kiev où une partie de la vie se déroule
désormais sous terre cette femme s'est
installée avec ses deux enfants dans les
couloirs du métro
ils vont bientôt quitter la ville sans
elle
elle a choisi de rester
je préfère être ici à kiev parce que si
la situation se dégrade
je pourrais aider je suis infirmière
donc s'il ya des blessés j'aurai
forcément une utilité
encerclement progressif aux assauts
soudain et très violent les habitants de
kiev se prépare fébrilement à tous les
scénarios